I think your focus on fiscal stimulus is
really important how do we help American
families that live too often paycheck to
paycheck get through this difficult time
where they lose their job or otherwise
space or difficult circumstances I think
your leadership on fiscal stimulus is
really thought unappreciated and then
all of us in this room know that the
financial markets are looking to help
America the interest rates changes that
we've seen both to the Fed and the bond
markets create an unprecedent
opportunity for Americans to refinance
their mortgages at a dramatically lower
rate which is really good for American
households or to have the opportunity
buy the first house or a new house for
their growing families so the markets
have worked as we would help at this
moment of time to help provide stimulus
to the entire economy through meaning to
the lower interest rates please
President Gordon Smith hit house chase
do we do jamie is doing well I will and
I will she always do he's making great
progress so thank you thank you very
much for asking so the bank has very
rigorous resiliency plans both in United
States and around the world all of those
are underway right now all of our plans
are designed obviously to protect and
help our people and to protect consumers
and small businesses will be there with
forbearance plans will be there to waive
fees for consumers and small businesses
who are under stress and I think a very
fair question is are we still lending
and over the course of the last 40 days
at JPMorgan we've extended 26 billion
dollars worth of loans to both consumers
and small businesses and then as I said
over the last 40 days we looked a little
bit at the Seattle
which you know has been a you know a
center of the virus and economic growth
is still continuing so you know we see
it's cluttered slow down significantly
but people are still going to
restaurants for example we still see
that people are buying food to be
delivered by the new delivery services
and interestingly in the data we also
see the pull back is much more about
from a big older generation my age than
it is from the Millennial Generation
so millennial generation spend seems to
be holding up very well I think maybe a
pent up demand when this is done I think
that everything that maybe people are
living their homes I think you ever see
a tremendous pent up demand which
hopefully won't be in the too distant
future waiting for the customer small
business to call the banks we are
proactively reaching out to the customer
and small businesses waiving fees making
sure we can refinance alone when
possible we're seventy nine percent
versus last year and refi it's still
gonna take a little while to find out
how much the effect really is thank you
thank you very much anybody else
markets they're here they're strong
whether it be your very smallest
businesses the ad communities of the
community service report Thank You
detective all the sentiments that you
deserve mr. president and thank you for
convening the group I would also add and
echoing on something Rebecca said we're
also helping not just all the large
globally active banks but the 50-100
banks across the United States build
continuity and resiliency program so we
can keep the banking system open to
support our customers and clients who
are you know in many cases facing a time
with me that's what banks do to stick by
their customers in good times in the
challenging times and that's what all
the banks in the United States are doing
today very very focused on providing
credit for small businesses right now
perhaps to struggle so getting the
credit to them rapidly and also being
very lenient on your terms that's great
thank you very much and thank you all
you've heard that the financial system
strong and I'll echo that yes but for
those listening the country is really
strong you've done a fantastic job your
administration's
we're adding jobs we need to all be more
diligent in terms of our health
management we learned that out of
business is a long-term lesson
but at the end of the day the United
States of America my view is very
strongly that we need to remind
ourselves that part of getting through
excelling like this is about confidence
and supporting each other and having
hope for the future
and for myself I believe our best baby
boy I'm working together thank you very
much thank you very much so I'll be
making a statement tonight probably at 8
o'clock and we'll be starting some
additional issues we made a great
decision on China and Asia and their
healing and their healing a pretty good
rate happy about that and we could start
to think about getting back involved in
that part of the world and as you know
we have another part of the world Europe
that's a very tough shape having a hard
time right now with the virus and we'll
be making various decisions you'll be
hearing about them at approximately 8
o'clock tonight Steve restrictions on
Europe are you thinking are you going
out I'll be letting you know that a
little bit later are you going to be
declaring a national disaster in the
past of industries that are too big to
fail in your estimation are the airlines
are the cruise lines is the hotel
industry too big to fail I think they're
going to be great
the folks around this table the ones
that finance it and they understand
they're great companies but we're we're
having to fix a problem that four weeks
ago nobody ever thought would be a
problem nobody you read about him you
read about it from 1917 and you read
about him from lots of other times but
nobody thought that we would be seeing
we were just discussing that this came
out of nowhere and actually came out of
China which is the way it works but we
are going to get the problem solved the
country is so strong the institutions of
the past had problems with institutions
you know powerful institutions that
built up there ready to go and I know
they'll be helping their customers
during this short term period we think
it's going to be a short term what they
think sort of stimulus package or
measures might need to be made as a
respondent I mean it's actually a very
good question I'm going to ask it myself
if you've been hearing about the various
forms for a stimulus different very
different forms of stimulus what would
you say it would be good appropriate
under these circumstances I think the
first thing is that fiscal stimulus at
the time of stress is the absolutely
right answer I think anything gets out
to the most people and so keeping people
who are become underemployed or
unemployed through this hole under wages
they're somehow supplementing that's run
employment another types of programs we
think is a key thing because if you keep
the two Broke of American people with
cash flow and money to buy goods and do
things the economy will be strong and
those individuals will have other people
we should take care of another question
you know all our companies anybody who's
out for this virus is getting paid for
as long as it takes or anybody has high
risk we're all taking care of it so I
I'd focus first on on that level and
then the second major thing is take care
of the health code
because the healthcare problem as well
generate so between testing and building
up the hospital's they can receive and
do great work America medical community
and hospital community can do where the
patient's is critical so it's it other
than broad base of people in the
hospitals I think businesses and other
things will get through this but if we
take care of those things that's
incorrect pretty quick if we get rid of
the problem quickly everything
themselves itself we don't need stimulus
so that'd be good but we are talking
about various forms of stimulus what
would you think Michael I think Adams or
what Brian said the support of small
business is critical right you look at
the employment you look at the
importance across our economy and
unfortunately right now small business
is suffering from both sides wonders
there's been disruption in their supply
chains in terms of receiving their goods
that they need and the second the other
side of is that there's uncertainty from
the demand side in terms of what the
future holds so I think working with the
banks in this room and well beyond the
SBA to be able to put programs in place
around forbearance to be able to
potentially up the limits in terms of
lending in these programs and again I
think with things that have been used
before effectively and I think we can we
can do it again thank you very much
I think all of us in this room are very
fortunate we're in a position to take
care of our workforce and I know that
that large corporate America is there
are a hundred and ten percent for their
employees the weak spot are the smaller
businesses that don't have the financial
flexibility and in particular our
workers who are part of the gig economy
how do we think about where necessary
direct fiscal support to the individuals
in our economy who are released secure
in their employment we work for IBM
life's gonna be fine you work for
Goldman Sachs like it's going to be fine
and if you are part-time or gig worker
this is a moment of real triumph and
this is where fiscal accommodation can
be quite powerful holiday it is a
regressive tax and it's something that
could help in the short run and long
term and they'll provide and will
support for the 70% of you have to need
some help in terms of all savings and
stability of livelihood and maybe to do
something I think so I think the payroll
tax would be great
Democrats are not in favor of it I'm
trying to figure out why because it
would be something that would be very
good for the citizens for the people and
even a longer term for the country so
that's a tax that people have long been
talking about either cutting or getting
rid of entirely Steve just say it's
great boys have the bankers in because
you have tremendous
into the economy what's going on and we
are interested in hearing that feedback
particularly its small and medium-sized
businesses in particular industries
we've catalogued for the president
all his executive authorities which are
quite significant so there'll be various
proposals he'll be rolling out quickly
on that front and we're also working
with Congress on a bipartisan basis to
be able to immediately help small and
medium sized businesses as well that
you're not taking this seriously enough
and that some of your statements don't
match what your health experts are
saying economic or with it within 50
feet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello from Milan which is the epicenter
of the coronavirus crisis in Italy
nowadays you can still have lunch in
restaurants for now at least
but you can't have dinner every bar
restaurant pops close at 6:00 p.m. you
can still go outside to buy food you can
go to cross grocery you can go at a
bakery just one person at a time inside
the shop you can't go shopping in malls
if you're a girlfriend or boyfriend
lives in another city you can't go to
visit him or her you can go to help your
elder parents or grandfathers but just
if you really need to and if they seek
help if they're fine you can go to visit
them you can still get a bus on a bus to
go to work
still the local government has asked a
premier Conte to ban all non-essential
activity for the next 15 days in that
case public transportation will be
halted but as you can see at the moment
there's not many people on on the line
to wait for a bus for the moment you can
still go to the barber shop but you have
to book your appointment and just one
person at time can be inside the barber
shop with a barbershop of zero you can
still go to work but if you really have
to be physically in the office work from
home is strongly recommended at the
moment you can get outside your place
for a walk go for a run
or you could take your dog outside but
you can make any other sporting
activities gyms are closed soccer games
that other games are banned until April
the 3rd including the Serie matches you
can still take trains and places if you
have to move inside the country but you
have to have justified business or
healthy reason you have to compile a
form and policemen will stop you at the
train station or at the airport gate
asking while you're getting outside your
city
[Music]
the problem in Libya is that there are
too many children with heart disease for
one surgeon operating on their
cardiologists spread out all over the
country there's only one surgeon you
only know about 300 cases here so after
the Revolution we came in and we started
working in these I think that if you
look at the number of children that
we've been able to operate since we've
been here it's now up to around a
thousand kids on both sides of the
country
we're on both sides of the conflict zone
and that is a specific goal are we able
to help the children you can create a
sort of medical diplomacy between the
two sides of the country utilizing the
children with heart disease as an issue
to bring them together over training is
critical for these individuals because
we're never be here forever
and we shouldn't leave your fruit we
should be leaving behind independent
sustainable operating teams and care
games and that's what we're trying to do
so we believe that by showing up by
being apolitical by taking care of the
children by providing education we can
show people in these other countries
where the perception of the miracle
might not be so good but guess what
people in the United States are not
necessarily the government we're
individuals who can bridge the gap and
bring cultures together
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
we have enough time to enjoy the life
enjoy a life a little bit
[Music]
they always feel like if you work from
home you can have more freedom about
things you do and how you structure your
day and usually get up early in the 6:30
just because the long distance between
my home and my